[Musique]
bonsoir c'est l'histoire d'un gamin qui
révèle des journalistes dès l'âge de 9
ans c'est l'histoire d'un ado qui
faisait chaque jour des fiches des
articles du groupe qui retient son
attention
il savait pas trop ce qu'ils allaient
faire de ces fiches et à vrai dire elle
jaunisse depuis la fin des années 80
dans une vieille boîte en bois vous
l'aurez deviné ce gamin c'est moi ma
passion du journaliste est née mes
voyages chaque année pendant un mois
l'été en parts avec ma mère le sac au
dos dans un pays différent
ces voyages m'ont permis de vivre des
moments vraiment rigolo comme cette fois
où je me suis retrouvé sur le toit d'un
bus au guatemala accroché au filet qui
retenaient les bagages des nuages ont
commencé récemment claude tour notre
tête et ma mère il a remaniement crépus
qui pleuvent
je ne croirais pas une averse nous est
tombé dessus on s'est retrouvés trempés
jusqu'aux os
trempés jusqu'aux os ce métier a
beaucoup évolué aussi au fil du temps et
un autre voyage qui m'a beaucoup marqué
et celui que j'ai passé en inde du nord
j'étais assez jeune à l'époque et nous
sommes allés dans ce pays
j'ai vécu là-bas des des moments très
forts je passais du dégoût à
l'émerveillement plusieurs fois par jour
dans des moments très court les le même
coucher de soleil pouvait donner des
couleurs extraordinaires à la façade du
taj mahal et rendent encore plus haut
rejoignant tu les crémations sur les
bords du gange à bénarès tous
bousculaient dans ma tête et je crois
que c'est durant ce voyage qu une envie
irrépressible m'a pris je voulais
comprendre le monde dans lequel je vis
hallyday est pour moi le journaliste
allait m'aider à faire ça et met donc
apparu tout naturel de devenir
journaliste
lors de mon entretien d'entrée au celsa
un membre du jury m'a demandé qu'est ce
que vous allez faire si vous n'êtes pas
accepté je lui dis sans même réfléchir
je sais pas mais je trouverais un moyen
d'être journaliste
embauché à 19 ans dans un journal qui
s'appelle le nouvel économiste un
collègue m'a dit un jour toi si on dire
par la porte
tu rentreras par la fenêtre et il avait
raison
voilà maintenant trente ans que je suis
journée
trente ans rien que dire ce mot me donne
un coup de vieux et à vrai dire mon
métier a beaucoup changé durant ces 30
derniers rangs ces trente dernières
années
tout va plus vite et il n'y a jamais eu
autant de médias vous n'avez jamais lu
autant de news sur vos smartphones sur
tablette
et pourtant les journalistes n'ont
jamais eu aussi peu de temps ni de
moyens pour bien travailler
voilà le paradoxe au moment de notre
profession et on est pris dans une
espèce de deux boucles où il faut
toujours aller plus vite la chaîne
d'informations en continu fonds directs
sont même avoir rien à dire j'ai moi
même travaillé pour l'une d'entre elles
pour couvrir un attentat à munich
je devais passer toutes les 15 minutes
en direct entre deux prises avec tant de
voir personne des centaines de milliers
de personnes ne regardait et j'avais
rien à leur dire
en voilà le paradoxe de ce métier l'ère
du tout gratuit est passée par là mais
mais pour comprendre un peu l'évolution
du métier je vous propose de faire un
voyage dans le passé de revenir au début
des années 90 c'était les années fastes
du journalisme 6,7 l'excès ce que les
années que j'appellerai les années
champagne après un stage d'un mois en
fin de première année de journalisme au
celsa j'ai été embauché en cdi au nouvel
économiste
à l'époque les médias bas encore des
moyens pour donner des moyens à donner
aux journalistes pour travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
je veux mon premier stage je les fais à
libération et c'était la paire de la
première guerre du golfe il avait envoyé
là bas un grand reporter qui refusaient
de rentrer à paris
parce qu'il avait encore des histoires à
couvrir et le journal lui payer ses
frais sort chine et ce serait
inimaginable aujourd'hui par la
parallèle parallèlement à ça tout tout
semblait plus facile pour travailler la
liaison poulet vous pouvez faire des
voyages de presse beaucoup plus
intéressants souvent dans l'excès je
dois dire je me rappelle de ce voyage ou
un jour un groupe papetier nous envoyer
un val d'isère on y allait en
orient-express avec professeur de ski
cascade de glace chiens de traîneau
alors qu'ils avaient rien à dire c'est
vraiment un ça c'était pas très bien
cette période a mais on avait aussi les
moyens de travailler mieux de faire plus
de reportages et ça c'était quand même
nettement plus intérêts nettement plus
intéressant c'est daniela en fait on
appris le métier m'ont fait croire que
tout était plus facile mais les l'état
semblait avoir plus d'argent
jument de mes premiers voyages de la
presse je les fais au koweït
qu'un ministre juste après la fin de la
première guerre du golfe et en fait dès
mon arrivée à l'aéroport j'avais été
choquée par tous ses avions ses charters
qui arrivé d'inde et du pakistan ont
rempli des migrants au fait qu avait
fait venir les comédiens pour la servir
de personnel de maison
parce que jusqu'à maintenant les
personnels de maison l'ena ni les
cuisiniers les chauffeurs à koweït city
étaient des palestiniens et la palestine
avait soutenu saddam hussein pendant
laquelle la conquête du koweït
donc les koweïtiens avaient demandé aux
palestiniens à partir et les remplacer
par des indiens lors d'un dîner officiel
je me suis retrouvé assis à côté d'une
sommité locale qui m'a raconté qu'il est
que pendant toute la guerre du golfe en
fait ils avaient été cachés par un de
ses domestiques palestiniens cette
personne avait pris des risques
inimaginable il aurait pu être assez
signer s'ils avaient été pris la main
dans le sac alors je vais demander
comment il avait remercié a évidemment
ses domestiques il m'a expliqué non je
leur envoyais halal chez lui ces gens là
on peut pas leur faire confiance
ce genre d'anecdote on ne peut les
trouver qu en allant sur place qu'en
faisant du reportage qui est de plus en
plus rare aujourd'hui de plus en plus
difficile en 95 je me suis aperçu que
j'avais oublié un petit détail je
n'avais pas fait mon service militaire
et comme je ne voyais pas du tout faire
le pew pew sur un champ de manoeuvre
dans la meuse
j'ai demandé à mon journal de m'envoyer
comme coopérant correspondant à londres
donc j'ai passé 16 mois là bas
correspondant pour eux ça s'est bien
passé j'étais supposé rentrer à paris en
fait j'ai fait énormément pris goût au
métier de correspondant
mais j'ai pas voulu rentrer j'ai donc
demandé à mon journal de me passer en mi
temps et c'est à ce moment là où j'ai
commencé à travailler pour d'autres
titres en parallèle et à cette époque
c'était encore assez simple trouver des
collaborations les journées avaient des
moyens d'envoyer en reportage en outre
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
après cinq ans arrive le nouveau
millénaire je me suis dit c'est le
moment vraiment de faire le rêve de ma
vie le rêve de ma vie c'était de faire
tour du monde pendant un an avant de
partir je suis allé à paris faire le
tour des rédactions pour lequel je
travaillais et du rang de ces rencontres
j'ai rencontré le patron de l s
acquittent à un canard de distré sur la
grande distribution et qui m'a tout de
suite demandé si je comptais travaillé
pendant ce tour du monde
et à vrai dire l'idée ne m'avait même
pas traversé l'esprit et judy mais comme
une véritable vague j'ai quand même pas
de faire le tour du monde à la grande
distribution et du tout génial cris -
budget comme j'avais encore eu du tout
de le faire je demande une somme que
jules est astronomique et il m'a tout de
suite dit banco
et voilà comment un journal
professionnel à appuyer plus la moitié
de mon tour du monde
dans 23 pays différents autres tu
entends dire que ça n'arriverait pour
aujourd'hui
à mon retour au tour du monde on est
aidé en été en 2001 j'ai voulu rester
correspondant repartir à l'étranger je
suis donc allé voir le monde et je leur
ai proposé de devenir correspondant pour
le pacifique sud basé à sydney ils ont
accepté m'ont donné les paquets pour les
visas et cette année là en fait ce
changement de continent a marqué la fin
des années champagne et début d année
cocktail pour bien bosser
il fallait que je mutualisent donc je
voyageais à peu près six à huit mois par
an reportage très bien je vais pas me
plaindre mais il fallait que je
l'utilisé sur plusieurs titres donc le
monde me payer mon billet d'avion
l'express me paye mon hôtel le point me
payer mes frais de bouche et allez ça
mais taxi est comme ça j'arrive à vivre
des choses vraiment extraordinaire qui
ferait rêver je pense beaucoup
d'étudiants en journalisme pour couvrir
la grande barrière de corail j'ai passé
15 jours sur un bateau de recherche à
plonger dans des eaux infestées de
crocodile avec la main sur le couteau
dont ça fait un petit peu peur
un soir je me rappelle soudain très
belle une autour d'un feu avec des
aborigènes je me suis dit j'ai quand
même chance monstrueuse de faire ce
boulot c'est aussi durant cette période
j'ai fait beaucoup plus de sujets
diffère entre de beaucoup de
journalistes sportifs
j'ai couvert l'austrian open la coupe
davis la coupe de l'america j'allais en
asie à peu près deux fois par an pour
faire le plein de reportages et remplir
les cas c'est aussi un petit peu ce
qu'il faut faire ça de temps en temps et
j'ai fait ça comme ça jusque jusque
jusqu'en années 2005 et à l'année 2005
j'ai voulu rentrer en europe donc je
suis je suis reparti en europe je me
suis basé en allemagne à munich
et là j'ai très vite compris que les
années cocktail a laissé place au régime
à l'eau plate - journaux - de pagination
moins d'argent
même les grands titres faisait des
économies je me rappelle d'un journal
économique qui m'a demandé de faire une
tâche entière sur une entreprise en
suisse
autant dire que l'entreprise c'est tout
près de chez moi mes frais n'avait pas
dépassé 400 euros
et quand je leur a dit cette somme ils
m'ont dit fait le de la maison ça sera
tout aussi bien ça aurait été
inimaginable quelques années plus tôt
alors bien sûr on peut faire ce papier
il sera pas trop mauvais mais il ne sera
jamais aussi riche qu'à reportage sur
place on viendra avec plein de
rencontres et d'anecdotes
mais si aujourd'hui comme ça qui s'est
aujourd'hui comme ça qu'on travaille et
je travaille également de pour de plus
en plus de sites web
ce qui est très intéressant parce qu'il
nous offre une grande liberté de parole
de ce type d'écriture et de sujets mais
ça paye beaucoup moins que les anciens
magazines donc il faut faire beaucoup
plus de volume aujourd'hui je crie avait
entre cinq et sept meetings par jour ce
qui est vraiment pas mal mais on y
arrive on y arriveront toujours dans
l'utile et l'agréable c'est à dire en
essayant de trouver des sujets assez
rapidement fait ou on peut gagner de
l'argent pour avoir des fonds pour faire
des reportages plus long et qui met plus
de temps
alors bien sûr on pourrait céder au
misérabilisme et dire que rien ne va
mais si on prenait la chose à l'envers
et coria la période actuelle comme une
opportunité
si les médias donnaient aux lecteurs à
vous public ce que vous recherchez
est ce que ces derniers n'acceptent et
rennes accepterait-il pas de payer pour
être informé certains exemples montrent
que c'est possible
mediapart à 150 mille abonnés le new
york times en a 3 8 millions chaque mois
3,8 millions acceptent de payer pour
être informé dans les kiosques
on voit de plus en plus de magazines qui
apparaissent avec des reportages à
l'ancienne très long des analyses très
fouillée et les gens les achètent
le public veut de l'authenticité de la
fiabilité du sens de la qualité
et quand on lui donne ça une partie
d'entre eux acceptent de payer et ça
c'est un signe positif alors encore une
fois je veux pas tomber dans la critique
de c'était mieux avant je sais que les
journalistes sont accusés souvent de
tous les maux on n'est pas les derniers
pour se plaindre
c'était mieux on pouvait mieux
travailler mais ce métier reste quand
même un des plus beaux du monde
il nous permet de vivre des choses
extraordinaires il y a deux ans pour
l'express je devais faire un papier sur
le navigateur françois gabart j'ai passé
24 heures sur son trimaran géant au
large de la bretagne à 42 noeuds les
dauphins n'arrivais même pas à nous
suivre
oui je bossais là il ya quand même pire
leur dernier pour géo je suis allé à
berlin pour que vous faire un reportage
sur cette ville trente ans après la
chute du mur il ya trente ans le mur et
tout le système qui représentait s'est
effondré un peu comme nos métiers
mais berlin aujourd'hui connaît un
renouveau extraordinaire des quartiers
dévastés
anciennement dévasté semble aujourd'hui
rempli de café in de restaurants sympas
de start-up mon métier n'en est pas
encore là mais je veux rester optimiste
je pense que si l'ère du tout gratuit
si l'air de l'info bon marché vite
consommé vite oublié prenait fin on
pourrait enfin arriver à une nouvelle
renaissance du journalisme je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]